we begin with this the White House is
taking action against turkey a NATO ally
as the u.s. scrambles to end Turkish
attacks on Kurdish forces in northern
Syria president Trump signed an
executive order imposing sanctions
against Turkey's government and several
Turkish officials the White House is
also sending a delegation led by Vice
President Mike Pence and new national
security adviser Robert O'Brien now they
will try to negotiate a ceasefire with
Turkey Turkey's invasion and attack on
the Kurds followed president Trump's
decision to withdraw US troops from
northern Syria but the White House
insist Turkey was planning to invade
Syria no matter what and the president
is just protecting US soldiers Turkey's
invasion of northern Syria highlights
the complicated relationship between the
u.s. turkey and the Kurds it's the
latest chapter in a long history of
tension in the region the roots of
turkeys offensive against the Kurds date
back nearly a century the Kurds are a
largely Muslim ethnic group native to
the Middle East they have their own
language culture and traditions at the
end of World War one Western powers
promised the Kurds an independent state
but it never happened instead the Kurds
are among the largest groups of people
in the world without estates at least 20
million strong spread out across Turkey
Iraq Iran and Syria but statelessness
hasn't kept the Kurds from being an ally
of the United States
the Kurds joined US forces to topple
Saddam Hussein during the Iraq war we
offered a today and became key partners
in the fight against Isis these Kurdish
fighters trying to move in that
direction and retake the main road to
Mosul which set the stage for today
for years a Kurdish militant group
calling for more autonomy has launched
violent attacks in Turkey turkey sees
the Kurdish fighters in Syria as being
linked with that militant group so when
President Trump pulled US troops out of
northern Syria we want to bring our
troops back home Turkey moved in
pledging to remove the Kurds and create
a so-called safe zone where at least a
million refugees displaced by the Syrian
civil war would be returned and with US
troops out of the area the Kurds are now
turning to two u.s. adversaries Syrian
dictator Bashar al-assad and Russian
President Vladimir Putin for protection